on accueille sur ce plateau à nicolas
gondry bonsoir nous parler de ce dernier
scrutin pour l'année 2010 est sont les
sénatoriales 170 parlementaires vont
être élus ce dimanche 24 septembre et
notamment pour occuper les six sièges
des yvelines qui seront renouvelées
comment qui sont pardon qui sont pour
commencer on va on va comme on va leur
apprendre à les connaître qui sont les
sénateurs sortants des yvelines alors
vous allez les voir à l'image quatre
sénateurs républicains et deux sénateurs
à part apparenté à gauche parmi eux on
retrouve évidemment le président du
sénat gérard larcher
un mandat qu'il assure depuis 2014 et
qu'il avait déjà détenu entre 2008 et
alors c'est un scrutin parfois méconnus
par les français comment sont élus ces
parlementaires
alors écoutez grégory vous n'aurez pas
besoin de vous déplacer aux urnes de ce
dimanche tout comme moi d'ailleurs et
certains de nos téléspectateurs
c'est une élection au suffrage universel
indirect c'est à dire que seuls les
grands électeurs sont appelés
obligatoirement aux urnes ils sont près
de 3000 dans les yvelines
parmi eux on retrouve les députés les
sénateurs sortants les conseillers
régionaux et départementaux ainsi que
des délégués municipaux dans les
yvelines six sièges sont à pourvoir et
particularités de ce scrutin
il est proportionnel et plurinominal les
grands électeurs vont voter en fait pour
des listes et les distributions des
sièges se fait proportionnellement par
exemple pour gagner un siège dans les
yvelines il faut obtenir un minimum de
486 voix
si vous en obtenez le doute vous gagné
deux sièges et ainsi de suite et les
sièges restants sont attribués à la plus
forte moyenne
et quelles sont les missions du sénateur
finalement alors les sénateurs sont élus
pour six ans avec un renouvellement par
moitié tous les trois ans il représente
les collectivités territoriales et comme
les députés du contrôle l'action du
gouvernement fabrique discute et votent
les lois
dernière chose nicolas quelles sont les
candidats qui sont les candidats pour
ces élections qui auront lieu ce
dimanche 12 10 ont été déposées pour ce
scrutin est le principal enjeu les
républicains vont ils conserver leurs
sièges et même accroître leur nombre
alors au vu de la composition du corps
électoral c'est-à-dire la couleur
politique des grands électeurs la liste
de gérard larcher part favori mais
attention malgré
tous aux autres listes apparentées à
droite comme celle de jacques myard de
geneviève salsa ou de jean-frédéric
berceau autre enjeu la gauche va-t-elle
le conserver au moins un siège
là aussi la division règne quatre listes
au total écoutez eddie ait président du
parti radical de gauche des yvelines
c'est vrai qu'il ya un risque politique
parce que la gauche ne dispose pas de
sénateur mais il faut croire que les
conditions qui avaient été réunis au
précédent scrutin d'un large
rassemblement à gauche sur une base
programmatique et idéologique n'ont pas
été réunis cette fois ci puis nous
avions décidé de prendre nos
responsabilités nous avions des
engagements nous avions des réserves
vis-à-vis du gouvernement
nous avions des réserves vis-à-vis des
positions exprimées par une partie de la
gauche
puis nous avons notre propre identité
alors en embuscade on retrouve la
république en marche une liste composée
sans le modem contrairement aux
élections législatives le parti de
françois bayrou s'est allié à lui d i
dans les yvelines
de son côté le front national va tenter
aussi d'obtenir au moins un siège avec
des positions très tranchées sur les
collectivités territoriales
écoutez yasmine belmadi l'objectif c'est
déjà de rendre redonner du pouvoir aux
collectivités locales que sont la mairie
et le département
parce que pour nous c'est vraiment le
socle c'est ce qui fait la france est ce
qui fait le maillage territorial
notre objectif effectivement c'est la
suppression de la région merci nicolas
pour ces précisions le rappel est lié à
sénatoriales c'est au programme dimanche
prochain